well civil righty gains made Global
headlines when she tied with athlete
Leah Thomas who's a transgender swimmer
this is the person of course who's been
dominating now women's swimming in
America despite having competed
unsuccessfully as a biological male well
unlike many people in the same position
afraid of vilification abuse and
cancellation Riley spoke out about it
took a stand for women's athletes across
the world
and as a result of that Stan she was
last week physically assaulted and
abused and howled at after being invited
to speak at San Francisco State
University well this weekend I spoke up
for Riley Gaines in a debate on Bill
Maher's HBO show real time while
debating a democratic congresswoman
Katie Porter
we talked about people you know becoming
using things to kind of get likes and
get clicks that's not what she's doing I
mean I've got no truck for right against
personally but all I've seen her do is
stand up for women's rights to fairness
and equality she actually competed
against Leah Thomas and it was obviously
unfair Leah Thomas won one of the races
in the NCAA championships by 50 seconds
against a bunch of biological females
who simply couldn't keep up that cannot
be right it cannot be fair that is
something
that I trust I think our sporting bodies
should be dealing with and by the way
Riley is speaking up for herself
and that is her prerogative and I
respect her free speech I think she's
speaking up for pretty much every female
athlete in the world
now that debate was astonishing on
several levels firstly that it fell to
me and Bill Maher to defend women's
rights against a woman arguing against
them and secondly the audience packed
with liberal Californians a pretty woke
crowd normally were watching a famous
liberal comedian and cited
overwhelmingly with Bill and me
defending Riley Gaines and women's
rights to fairness so I'm joined Now by
Riley again so Riley great to see you
um I don't know whether you've got a
chance to actually watch what went down
on the bill Marshall but it was
fascinating to see the audience reaction
because they completely agree with me
when I defended you and did not agree
with the woman in the room
absolutely
um when I watched this back I eat
you don't but laugh
just like you mentioned it's ironic it's
always women fighting against women's
sex protected spaces and rights it blows
my mind but I so appreciate both you and
Bill standing up for myself because you
hit the nail on the head I'm speaking
for every female athlete not just myself
I'm done competing this isn't about me
um but I know it's at stake if someone
doesn't use their voice I have a younger
sister I just got married I can only
hope one day that I have a daughter and
I can't imagine being in this position
and not fighting for them but also I'm
fighting for the present female athletes
Leah Thomas's teammates even who have
their voices suppressed they see what
happens to me when I go to San Francisco
State and they don't want to put
themselves in a position where speaking
out would would Garner that for them
right so it's a lot bigger than just
myself and to see representative Katie
Porter even say that it just it clearly
shows she knows nothing about what I've
been doing this past year nothing has
been for personal advancement nothing
has been for monetary value for me
um my I was supposed to be in Dental
School this year so by no means did I
even feel equipped to do what I'm doing
this is not about me and and hearing her
say that showed her true ignorance yeah
I completely I completely agree and in
fact Leah Thomas today tweeted the
following it breaks my heart to see
trans kids across the country lose out
on these opportunities during the time
of anti-trans backlash the trans
Community needs explicit protections
from discrimination in order to live our
lives free and equally all trans kids
deserve the opportunity to compete and
play on the sports they love without
compromising who they are now my problem
with that and I think you picked up on
this as well in your response to Leah
Thomas is well what about fairness and
equality for the women for biological
females because clearly what Leah Thomas
a six foot four inch biological male who
did not compete successfully against men
but is now demolishing women in National
Championships clearly that is unfair now
I want trans athletes to have fairness
and equality I want them to be able to
play sport but not at the expense of
women's rights
exactly the first sentence you you said
I believe it was it Leah Thomas quoted
saying you know it breaks my heart to
see trans kids lose out on opportunities
you're exactly right replace that with
the word woman does it still break
Thomas's heart to see women lose out on
opportunities because that's exactly
what's happening from my experience
competing against Leah Thomas at the
national championships I watched
firsthand women lose out on
opportunities I watch women not become
all-americans missing that ninth or the
8th and 16th Place by one place because
they were displaced by a male this of
course goes against everything that
Title IX was created to protect and now
we have
um the Biden Administration the people
in the White House who are actively
working to rewrite title ix9 for those
who don't know originated in the 70s
were designed to bring equality and
fairness
irrespective of gender to schools and
education and in particular to school
Sport and clearly that is now not
happening and the Biden Administration
are effectively endorsing this
unfairness
absolutely that's exactly what they're
doing um Title IX it's a several civil
Federal rights law that insures women
essentially have the same opportunities
as men whether that be athletically
academically the same amount of
scholarships
we saw women fight for this in the 70s
we saw someone as as amazing as Billie
Jean King
um Megan rapino these are feminists who
fought for women's rights but now both
of these women along with the Biden
Administration they're actively working
to undermine everything they once fought
for well Megan rapino was out there
tweeting away that you know this is all
uh all fantastic and of course trans
athletes should be doing this and I made
the point uh well how would she have
felt if she'd lost her place I'm a
national women's soccer team which was
obviously they were world champions to a
trans athlete who was five inches taller
stronger faster and much better at
football but who have been unsuccessful
playing an immense team how would she
have felt then
well if you've ever seen Megan rapino
play she's a very tough aggressive
player so I can tell you exactly what I
think she would have done
um I think she genuinely would have
shift someone who tried to take her spot
a male who tried to take her spot and I
think it's worth mentioning that she's
done playing she has nothing to lose she
doesn't have a daughter to defend so for
her what to lose by by almost virtue
signaling by coming off as kind and
inclusive and welcoming and accepting
and tolerant and loving and all the
things but in reality it's not kind to
ask a girl to share a locker room with a
man who's fully equipped with and
exposing male parts and it's not
inclusive to ask a woman to smile and
step aside on the podium so a man can
take her Trophy and take her spot in her
honors yeah I just find this whole
debate completely baffling I don't
understand why every woman in the world
wouldn't join together and say this is
outrageous and it's the treachery from
women like the Democrat congresswoman
Katie Porter like Megan rapino like
these others who who should be doing a
lot better than they are but you know
what a lot of women are scared they're
scared to do what you've done you know
you went to San Francisco State
University and you know you you're a
fear of your life with that mob and it
was terrifying
absolutely it sure was I was essentially
I mean I know you saw the video but I
was physically assaulted and I was held
from ransom for three hours I mean these
people who barricaded me in this room
they were demanding money if I wanted to
make it home safely which then the dean
of students was actually negotiating
with them it's like you know why are we
negotiating my safe passage home this is
crazy but you're exactly right and these
girls they're terrified they're scared
parents are even scared they don't want
to lose their job coaches athletic
directors no one wants to be in a
position where you you ruffle feathers
or step on toes but that's what it's
going to take it's going to take
sacrifices it's going to take girls not
willing to get up on that starting block
not jump when the gun blows we need
people who are willing to take that next
step and I know it's unfortunate that
it's come to this circumstances to have
to make change but that's what it's
going to take Riley you're a gutsy woman
I've got to tell you I've got great
admiration for you and what you go
through to make this point because it's
so important it's basically lately the
Integrity of women's sport is at risk
real risk of being irrevocably destroyed
and I think that people like you should
just be applauded by women around the
world and making the standard doing a
great personal risk to yourself so well
done to you keep it going and you'll
always have me in your corner of course
thank you so much Pierce all the best
thanks Roddy